a fornalha formado por tatá para isso
jacuzzi privado am ontem uma bela praia
é o fundo eu vou lá hoje e vamos falar
sobre descontextualizar eu vim passar
uma semana que ainda nos canais que nós
temos procurado muita coisa lá no inter
e grêmio histórias fotos quando chegam
mas consegue ainda sobraria para tudo e
associado pelo item investimento é coisa
nova está a ser muito louco mesmo mas
com uma das coisas mais loucas que
encontrei aqui na ilha dúvida isso é que
são figuras fortemente em baladas que
pensa que transportam um filmete
mistério segundo se você joga o formato
eo também jovem adoro joguei muito bem
por isso prosseguiu por aqui dentro mas
é que isso não é oficial não compreende
numa loja oficial formato eu não sei se
existe um oficial e embalagem impura
tudo é que nada a ver com fortunati e do
nós vamos ver isso e acho que vai ser
muito engraçado que eu tenho quase
certeza conquistar aqui dentro não
correspondem à realidade do fox life vai
ser muito bom eu acho que cumprimos 10
tem uma duas três quatro cinco seis sete
oito nove dez 10 figuras e se vocês
repararem bem nem todas as embalagens
são iguais tipo de embalagem é mais
pequena cá atrás em outra imagem e este
aqui são maiores e dá para trás tem
outra imagem então isso nem sequer é
igual eles também são diferentes bombado
que meu deus estará muito boa eu quero
muito ver o que tem aqui dentro só
comentei embaixo vocês já viram algumas
dessas cenas feitas à venda tanto em
portugal ou no brasil comenta e se
existe aí é porque eu nunca vi isso ea
venda então não pode fazer uma coisa
nova que o youtube fez linda então só
vocês possam formar se quiserem ver
assim mais vídeos sobre coisinhas destas
comentem muito em baixo que querem
deixem muito lá e competir em e bora lá
então abrir as nossas riquezas maior
acho muito curioso museus qualquer só
agora a primeira 53 9 em maio do vídeo
que esteja coligado mas vamos lá abrir
meu deus o que é craque
ai ai
não tem nada a ver
olha eu nunca vi esta personagem no
fórum mas só comentei isso esta postagem
existe no formato porque já não joga há
cerca de duas semanas
ia estava em outra e falta quinta na mão
falta de tinta que não têm material está
te conhece um plástico duro não para
pelo menos mesmo o casamento está muito
poder tá muito mal pintava eu não sei se
conseguirá que o menor mas falta pintar
lei falta de internet a mão mas sim mas
com eles aqui dentro
rui mário é uma pistola lei que não dá
pra colocar um boneco não isso não
funciona a dell ter um final deus não
seria muito podre não é muito pouco
ganhamos lá isso aqui parece mais dura e
parece um boneco melhor o carro e este
aqui eu tenho pressa
vem com um funk cartas mas não é oficial
não estava em poder estar 100
está comendo são bem o primeiro-ministro
não dá ataque isso tem ataque e defesa
também está aqui deve ser um jogo de
cartas que deve apresentar leis não são
assim tão poucos atentamente tampada
aqui mas discordo por estar melhores
podia ter mais tinta sei lá estudar
assim meio da manhã o sol fica a cinco
do nosso personagem só com uma qualidade
muito não está muito melhor mas não sei
se ele for na próxima fase
eu já vi eu acho que desde o pacote mais
barato 2 47 euros
eu acho que está bem feito sem o
equipamento vai estar bem colorido e sim
mas eu também não sei se estivesse tão
forte no haiti existe ninja
eu juro ou eu sou o tumulto e saibam
sair não
atenas bem espadas rua próxima à criança
procurou colocar as palavras nem podre
não entra e se não dá isso não dá pra
encaixar a mão eu não tenho horário em
que acha que sua espada
eu só posso dar uma opinião também foi
um ninja bem louco o que é isso que o
próprio 22 que saíram bem isso aqui não
sair este que está parece que lula
entendeu se que um camarão e frango nos
parece querer as meninas próxima
embalagem
ok eu quero uma das boas que a embalagem
mais pequena é que aqui eu tenho
esperança que saia alguma coisa de jeito
já o salto da igreja 21 imagem
não conheço este texto é um mágico
também foi de tamanha chamado mas eu não
tinha também no formato
este é o boneco eu penso que é um
vampiro machico com o cartola mais de
meio milhão não é nada porque nunca me
ajudou foi o primeiro momento e mesmo em
basto despistagem qual é que é oficial
você não ficar algum partido ou se é
mesmo isso não é comigo mesmo porque nem
eu tô perceber porque não queria estar
lá
nunca a ganhou com cartas formais
espanha que o dano se tem aqui que o
personagem louco eu tenho outra carta
com umas quatro e tem jogado aqui também
com uma equipa para isso esses sim são
os personagens oficiais informaram que
nenhum deus para a próxima imagem que
tem câncer em grande escala que os
grandes é bem alto o time principal que
vocês começam se excluírem san siro
mulher tenha posso colocar uma dentro do
mar é um arm igual às outras todas é
tudo igual é claro mas é tudo igual mais
um primeiro milagre
os miúdos vão comprar esta diretoria já
estão formados que ela está bem vai
projetar essa menina que queria nem
pensa em contar fazer investimentos
porque é mesmo o elemento desta
personagem é que esse comportamento na
sala do hotel né mas ela tem aqui umas
luvas e tem aqui uma luva no quintal e
um insulto
justamente por isso ele não tá pintar
pintaram tudo e tudo bem agora
inspiração a embalagem grande que tem a
mesma personagem que não dão o braço a
mesma arrasou próxima figura ainda assim
a personagem também vem com um hotel
também estão três embalagens de frança
que sair é que o personagem que o mesmo
igual igual ao pessoal da nossa sorte é
que eles querem ver mais vídeos desde
que eu posso comprar uns postagens e
tentar encontrar o velho oeste só se
apoiar em muitas conteúdo aí sim o site
faz mais porque não gostar tem 11 4813
abrir um grande salto na cabeça da
boneca bem bizarro não é muito bizarro
nunca vi um mac assim como a senhora
parece um pescoço para dentro não dá
nunca levei três personagens estão
fortes mas não era um personagem é uma
arma diferente porque veio como um
choque grande mas também estava em
português está bem feito socceroos de é
bem fininho isso aqui está parecendo
tempo mas a equipa está muito fininha lá
em casa aqui dentro da embalagem
seu estádio para a próxima fase
hum ok bem cartas e vamos prá primeiras
cartas ternos com o personagem que não
sei o nome eo pintor é o formato pintor
as pessoas de que a esquerda campanha
assim ó que é que eu vou ter uma
postagem nova e em 3 e em dois em um o
que é isto
não existe um bicho um fato lembra não
dá não dá isso aqui não pode ser
personagem oficial não tá agora não está
aí o pessoal só faltou o único só isso
que envolveu dentro da cozinha água
quente para quem tem assim costa
pessoal vamos lá gente tem que tentar
muita sorte série oc vamos lá vamos lá e
o ninja a mãe que temer só que vocês
acham desse estágio
o pessoal tá aqui as nossas personagens
tudo que nós conseguimos com estas
equipas mistério comenta y cola que
vocês acham que é mais parecida com uma
personagem do fortunati
mesmo assim eu acho que é esta porque a
personagem principal eu acho mas eu acho
que também tem uma esquina que eles
ninja é preciso pelo menos mas não é
igual e neste nem vou falar eu nem vou
falar estas mas cometeu o que vocês
acharam um software que eu abra mais
técnicas destas comentem muito mesmo
deixei muito claro que pretende um vídeo
e inscreva-se não foram inscritos e um
possível não posso comprar um saco tem
uma coisa gigante só conquistado em
festas e três só espero que vocês tenham
gostado e agora vou ter que buscar
porque tudo molhado
eis fique bem até a próxima